bonjour nous sommes le 25 octobre
vendredi dernier jour de la semaine
dernière JT pour la rédaction voici les
titres que nous allons développer ce
weekend il faudra reculer d'une heure
nous montre lancée afin de réaliser des
économies d'énergie la mesure est-elle
encore efficace réponse à suivre amateur
d'échecs à Montigny-le-Bretonneux le
club propose jusqu'à ce weekend son
douzième tournoi d'automne et son
premier tournoi de maître la dame noire
qui fête cette année c'est 25 ans et
puis l'invité de cette édition Laurence
cousin adjointe à la direction Yvelines
informations jeunesse à Versailles la
structure qui accueille conseil autour
de l'emploi des études du logement est
inquiète pour son avenir
ce week-end à 3h du matin dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche nous passons donc à
l'heure à divers un changement d'heure
prévu au départ pour faire des économies
d'énergie il est aujourd'hui remis en
cause notamment pour des dérèglements
biologiques qu'il provoquerait les
mondes réponse avec Olivier et
Maniscalco
le passage à l'heure divers c'est dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche comme
chaque dernier week-end d'octobre ne
reculeront donc nos montres d'une heure
oui mais au fait à part gagné une heure
de sommeil à quoi ça sert le changement
d'heure bah ils disent que ça fait des
économies mais je suis pas sûr c'est pas
une question d'économie d'énergie espace
que vu que les gens ils se lèvent à des
heures où il éclairage naturel etc ça
permet de pas utiliser l'éclairage des
villes je suppose soi-disant c'était
pour consommer moins le matin et le soir
je trouve que maintenant voilà ça pue
trop de je suis trop d'importance pas
grand chose à mon avis il fait nuit
quand on se lève et quand on rentre il
fait nuit aussi donc on est obligé
d'allumer la lumière donc du coup il y a
pas d'économie d'énergie pour moi mise
en place en 1976 le passage à l'heure
d'hiver permettait surtout à l'époque de
baisser notre consommation de pétrole
aujourd'hui la donne a bien changé les
économies d'électricité réalisée sont de
plus en plus modestes les équipements
ont évolués avec l'introduction des
ampoules basse consommation ou
l'éclairage public réglé sur la nuit
solaire mais pour certains le passage à
l'heure d'hiver est néfastes à notre
santé tout simplement parce que l'été
prochain processus inverse nous devrons
avancer nos montres d'une heure en ce
qui concerne les enfants il y a eu les
jeunes en général il y a eu une
féminale le professeur renouvelle qui
s'ennuient à la maturité du cerveau du
cgen et quand à l'ensemble des personnes
et bien c'est ça c'est de la santé c'est
un coup faut que la collectivité ce
changement d'heure continue de faire
débat en Espagne par exemple le
gouvernement réfléchit à une
modification de son fuseau horaire afin
de retarder les horloges de deux heures
tic tac tic-tac les pendules sont loin
d'être à l'heure
et n'oubliez pas donc de reculer vos
montres dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche les Yvelines comptent 500
entreprises de cosmétiques c'est un
secteur important et la cosmétique
Valley qui fait l'air plusieurs d'entre
elles a organisé cette semaine avec la
Chambre de commerce un congrès une
première olfaction et perspective
c'était la thématique utilisée les
odeurs dans le domaine de la santé du
marketing de l'environnement pourquoi
pas c'est une possibilité explication
avec ce reportage est de Claire Cambier
sur des images de Jonathan film
les métiers liés aux odeurs ne se
limitent pas à la parfumerie c'est le
message que souhaitait faire passer les
organisateurs du Congrès olfaction et
perspective qui se tenait ce jeudi à la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie c'est
aussi surtout de parler de tous vos
champs d'application de l'olfaction
parce que comme on l'a dit c'était un
sens qui a été pas mal oublié jusqu'à
aujourd'hui alors qu'en fait c'est un
sens qui va nous permettre finalement de
pouvoir ouvrir de nouveaux métiers d'une
grande ouverture en tout cas pour nos
jeunes aussi non seulement dans les
métiers classiques de la parfumerie de
la cosmétique ou dans l'alimentaire mais
aussi on l'a vu dans le domaine médical
on le verra dans le domaine de
l'environnement parmi les avancées
présentées la détection de maladies par
les odeurs ou encore le lien entre
émotions et odeurs appliqués au bien de
consommation si on veut positionner un
produit comme étant relaxant une cramine
à 30 comme un temps relaxante on
pourrait aussi proposer un parfum qui
aille dans ce sens là émotionnellement
pour ré renforcer et suggérer d'autant
plus ce pouvoir par exemple relaxant de
la crème c'est un peu ça l'idée donc
finalement pour nous en tant que
fabricant de parfum sélectionné nos
produits en fonction de certains
positionnements émotionnels finaux des
biens de consommation et des produits de
consommation les Yvelines représentent
un territoire clé de ce secteur sans
sans entreprise de cosmétiques qui sont
implantés ainsi que l'école easypars en
1970 par Jean-Paul Guerlain lui-même la
région
Île-de-France fait également partie de
la cosmétique vallée avec les régions
Normandie et centres c'est d'abord un
impact d'attractivité c'est que dans le
monde il y a rien de mieux donc c'est un
peu une Silicon Valley dans lesquelles
on crée en fait un mouvement qui associe
à la fois la recherche la formation les
PME la cosmétique va les représentent 18
milliards de chiffre d'affaires et
prévoit 1500 créations d'emplois d'ici
205 on passe à l'entretien cette édition
l'invité c'est Laurence cousin bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau la direction
d'Yvelines informations Genèse votre
structure on en parle assez souvent sur
cette antenne en raison des différentes
actions que vous menez envers les jeunes
autour de l'emploi du logement de la
santé aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas là
pour ça la structure connaît des
difficultés on va regarder ce reportage
d'Olivier Maniscalco qui a été réalisé
hier lors de la journée de mobilisation
de grève pour avoir quelques précisions
et puis on en discute juste après très
bien
le bureau Yvelines informations jeunesse
en danger c'est le message que ces
salariés souhaitaient faire passer en
manifestants ce matin dans les rues de
Versailles même si le financement du
bureau reste assuré par les
collectivités y j se heurte à un
problème de taille à compter du premier
novembre les salariés n'auront plus de
direction et plus de direction signifie
qu'en tant qu'association ils n'auront
légalement plus le droit d'exercer leur
mission en tant que salarié en fait on a
eu aucune information aucun retour sur
sur la suite sur le devenir d'yj on a
lancé aussi une pétition justement pour
qu'on soit soutenu par les partenaires
par les usagers par les Amis de
l'information jeunesse en général et d'y
en particulier plus on aura de
signataires plus on aura un poids
la pétition lancée par Yvelines
d'information jeunesse à récolter plus
de 156 signataires selon Laurence cousin
la DDCS des Yvelines a promis de se
pencher d'un peu plus près sur le cas
des sept salariés du bureau mais évoque
un vide juridique sur ce dossier Yi
espère être reçu par le conseil général
un de leurs partenaire financiers pour
rappel le bureau assure une information
aux jeunes du département concernant
l'orientation l'emploi ou le logement
voilà vous l'avez compris le problème
divine Information Jeunesse et ce manque
de direction au premier novembre vous
serez sans représentant son président
pour Yvelines informations jeunesse
c'est dans quelques jours comme on vous
est arrivé à cette situation et qui doit
décider au final de ce désignation d'un
président pour la structure alors on va
dire qu'effectivement ça a démarré
certainement l'année dernière puisque
l'ancien directeur
et sa femme il fonctionnait en couple
sont partis à la retraite c'est eux qui
sont à l'initiative de la création yjj
donc on peut imaginer effectivement que
l'après la prêt à poser problème on a eu
voilà on a une directrice effectivement
mais qui est restée moins de 6 mois à la
démarrer en juillet à la démissionné
début décembre notre président a
démissionné le 24 mai dernier ça fait
beaucoup de démission ça fait beaucoup
ça c'est une explication à ça
écoutez en tout cas en tout cas il y
avait le temps d'anticiper
sur le devenir YJ ça c'est pas fait on a
tout toutefois encore un bureau mais ce
sont trois personnes qui sont
démissionnaires qui étaient
démissionnaires déjà fin juin dernier
qui ont re-signé pour trois mois
supplémentaires mais depuis il ne s'est
rien passé alors nous comme vous le
disiez effectivement la question c'est
comment on peut faire mais il nous faut
absolument un président puisqu'on est
une association
alors il y a des membres du conseil
d'administration donc qui ont été
informés des difficultés divines
d'information jeunesse donc ça peut être
aussi un appel
vis-à-vis de ses membres du conseil
d'administration divine Information
Jeunesse vous interrompre qu'on
comprenne bien ces membres du conseil
d'administration ce sont des partenaires
financiers qui siègent au sein du
Conseil par exemple on a entendu parler
du conseil général comme partenaire
financier
au sein du conseil d'administration bien
entendu les décisionnaires pour des
années il y a les partenaires financiers
et puis après il y a le fonctionnement
d'une association donc ces membres du
conseil d'administration peuvent
demander une assemblée générale
extraordinaire parce que pour valider un
futur président et un trésorier et
éventuellement aussi un secrétaire
général il faut que ça passe par
l'assemblée par un assemblée générale
parce que nous en tant que salarié on ne
peut pas faire ce genre de réponse on
vous fait aujourd'hui alors
effectivement donc nous on a été amené à
faire cette grève et cette pétition pour
se faire entendre alors peut-être un peu
tardivement mais parce qu'on a cru que
ça allait
et voilà c'est c'est ça le degré
d'urgence est extrême donc l'idée ça a
été d'être entendu auprès justement des
des partenaires alors on a été reçu on a
été reçu hier par la Direction
Départementale de la Cohésion Sociale
donc c'est vrai que ils se sont voulu
rassurer ils nous ont écouté ils nous
ont entendu ils nous ont rappelé
d'ailleurs ce matin donc ils vont
essayer de voir parce qu'ils nous ont
bien dit qu'effectivement il y avait une
sorte de vie juridique et que
concrètement nous on leur disait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce qu'on peut
continuer nos missions en novembre il ne
savait pas donc
on pourrait peut-être pas continuer à
travailler en tout cas vous ne savez pas
vous serez devant le fait accompli tout
à fait vous serez pas payé comment ça va
on imagine on imagine que non on va voir
on ne sait pas personne pour expédier
les affaires il faut il faut il faut
lancer une procédure d'alerte pareil que
nous en tant que salariés on ne peut pas
lancer et c'est un administrateur après
qui prend qui prend la relève c'est une
structure qui existe aussi à travers la
France avec différentes structures et
des raisons nationales est-ce que c'est
déjà arrivé est-ce qu'il y a des
précédents sur ce type de situation
est-ce que d'autres ruptures ont des
difficultés aussi oui alors il y a des
difficultés effectivement l'information
jeunesse pas dans son ensemble mais
certaines régions ou départements
ont vécu déjà des difficultés parce que
c'est effectivement un problème aussi
politique tout dépend après de la
politique jeunesse qu'on veut mettre
dans sa vie dans sa région etc ce sont
sa politique locaux hein pas au niveau
national
puisque nos têtes de de réseau le CDJ
nous a soutenu hier lors de cette grève
et nous soutient aussi pour la pétition
parce que ils ont aussi connu des
difficultés structure et au niveau vous
savez la politique c'est priorité
jeunesse madame Fourneyron qui est la
ministre en charge de la jeunesse pour
l'instant on n'a pas forcément reconnu à
sa juste valeur l'information jeunesse
au niveau national donc à chaque niveau
il y a un moyen d'action nous notre
moyen d'action ça a été en tant que
salarié la manifestation et la pétition
qu'il faut qu'il faut toujours continuer
à alimenter par des commentaires sur
l'utilité de l'information jeunesse et
d'ygi en particulier donc sur le blog du
CDJ c'est idj en danger.com et on a créé
aussi une page facebook
YJ en danger comment ça va s'organiser
pour les prochains jours la semaine
prochaine sur les 7 derniers jours vous
allez continuer à aller travailler
normalement en attendant cette date
fatidique du 1er novembre et oui nous
assurons jusqu'au bout nos missions
d'accueil du public ça c'est pour nous
notre notre valeur ajoutée c'est c'est
l'accueil du public
malgré tout en parallèle on va continuer
à solliciter et informer
le plus grand nombre de personnes
possibles sur les difficultés qu'on vit
parce qu'on n'a pas assez communiqué sur
ces difficultés et aujourd'hui vous
attendez une réponse du Conseil
d'Administration exactement tout à fait
exactement on espère vraiment avoir des
représentants de l'ego pour continuer
nos missions au mieux et on fera un
point la semaine prochaine pour voir si
vous avez été entendu ben écoutez avec
grand plaisir pour revenir faire un
petit bilan de cette mobilisation merci
à vous merci beaucoup je rappelle donc
Evin Information Jeunesse est toujours
menacé on va dire presque de disparition
que nous devons en tout cas il n'y aura
plus de direction la pauvreté qui
progresse sur la concerne aussi les
seniors c'est le constat du Secours
populaire des Yvelines qui vient
d'organiser son congrès annuel une
paupérisation dont on parle finalement
assez peu les seniors ayant parfois
honte de solliciter des aides parce
qu'elle Rodier responsable de
l'association dans les Yvelines étaient
l'invité du journal lundi je propose
d'écouter un extrait de son intervention
on a un petit peu plus de 10% du public
qui a plus de 60 ans et ça il y a 4 5
ans en fait on ne voyait pas à cette
proportion là comment ça s'explique
alors cette évolution est-ce qu'il y a
une explication à donner contexte
économique difficile des retraites
trophées des parcours professionnels qui
fait que en fait de plus en plus les
gens n'ont pas leur trimestre et sont au
minima de la de la retraite sécu en fait
et quand vous êtes sur des périodes de
votre vie ou vous n'avez pu travailler
ou les indemnités ont baissé ça fait que
par exemple vous n'avez pas pu accéder à
la propriété pour rester locataire donc
avec des charges financières qui sont
pas pareils comme vous avez payé et puis
les loyers qui continuent à augmenter et
toujours le payer alors qu'en général
quand on arrive à la retraite on est
plutôt quand on a pu être propriétaire
c'est exactement la vie en fait il faut
avoir la chance de pouvoir accéder à la
propriété déjà avant 40 ans sinon après
ça se complique fortement et il y a
aussi je pense alors ça c'est un un peu
patientifique mais que l'on mesure comme
ça c'est l'éclatement des structures
familiales compliquent aussi
à des rebonds aussi bien dans les
âges les plus jeunes pour les enfants
que sur les générations dessus parce que
quand la famille devient monoparentale
souvent on enclenche une solidarité
familiale les parents des parents donc
nos aînés sont souvent mis à
contribution et tout ça tant les budgets
de un peu de tout le monde quoi ça fait
partie des populations qui
sociologiquement de enfin déjà sont
souvent plus discrètes et deviennent
invisibles on a en règle générale je
veux pas non plus hormis ceux qui font
du bénévolat au Secours populaire ou
dans d'autres associations le mais je le
dis en souriant mais en même temps c'est
sérieux souvent pour des personnes qui
ont quitté la vie professionnelle on se
désanonymise en faisant du du bénévolat
et le la grosse difficulté pour les
personnes de AG c'est que souvent c'est
un isolement physique sociale qui limite
aussi la perception par les travailleurs
sociaux il y a une réticence aussi et
puis c'est une question de dignité je
veux dire si vous avez travaillé élever
des enfants que vous arrivez à un âge
mur et que vous vous
subissez le fait d'avoir à vous adresser
à une structure pour pouvoir manger ou
faire des activités sociales culturelles
partir en vacances mais quelle
dégradation de l'image personnelle ça
peut représenter c'est terrible en fait
les seniors nous en avons également
parlé cette semaine sur notre antenne
dans le 7 8 l'actu avec Olivier de
Laporte conseiller général des Yvelines
qui pilote en ce moment la Semaine Bleue
une semaine dédiée aux personnes âgées
qui existent au niveau national et qui
permet en local de faire connaître les
actions qui sont menées on écoute
Olivier de la porte et on se retrouve
juste après pour la suite du 7 8 l'actu
de ce vendredi et donc département des
Yvelines est-ce que vous constatez aussi
cette cette poussée de nos aînés ils
sont de plus en plus nombreux oui on la
constate et je dirais le département des
Yvelines et en Île-de-France un des
départements avec l'Essonne qui va
connaître d'après les prévisions des
spécialistes une des plus fortes
poussées augmentation du nombre des
personnes âgées et ça c'est un élément
qui est très important alors c'est une
bonne chose d'abord on vit plus âgé on
vit mieux plus âgé et c'est un élément
dans la vie qui est essentiel mais ça
pose des questions des questions
d'accueil des questions d'accompagnement
des questions de d'appui de soutien
auprès des familles auprès des aidants
familiaux de professionnalisation des
métiers de la personne qui exigent
évidemment l'effort des professionnels
et du conseil général bien entendu quel
est le budget justement consacré par le
conseil général
dont 60 millions de personnes âgées et
40 millions aux personnes en situation
de handicap alors dans les 60 millions
pour les personnes âgées je dirais 40 35
à 40 millions pour les personnes âgées à
domicile et 40 millions pour les
personnes âgées en établissement et dans
le cadre de la Semaine Bleue cette
semaine dédiée donc aux personnes âgées
il y avait plusieurs manifestations
parmi ces différentes pilotées par le
Conseil Général des Yvelines un
spectacle éducatif sur les dangers de la
route les personnes âgées au volant
c'était à la verrière et Yolaine Torres
Patrick Jacques de dixmu dont assisté à
la représentation alors depuis combien
de temps conduisez-vous depuis que j'ai
9 ans et demi ça fait 90 ans maintenant
retour quelques années en arrière pour
ces seniors à La Verrière il révise
quelques règles de bonnes conduites au
volant à travers un spectacle interactif
si vous conduisez depuis longtemps
voilà donc puisque nous sommes tous les
deux des conducteurs seniors nous allons
vivre ensemble avec le public qui porte
des lunettes ici alors voilà donc des
personnes qui pourront participer
la prévention routière un sujet parfois
difficile à aborder avec les personnes
âgées le fait de ne plus pouvoir
conduire représente souvent pour elle
une perte d'autonomie supplémentaire ils
ont parfois du mal à comprendre que
malgré l'autonomie physique qu'ils
peuvent avoir à conduire encore leur
véhicule cela peut représenter un danger
pour eux-mêmes également pour les autres
donc l'idée c'est vraiment de les
sensibiliser au danger de la route ce
qu'il pourrait rencontrer mais au danger
peut même pourrait représenter et là
c'est la pluie c'est la douche alors que
faites-vous vous réduis certains ont
redécouvert quelques règles du code de
la route ou vous arrêtez votre véhicule
c'est vrai que j'ai appris des choses
que j'avais sûrement oublié ou que je ne
connais de je ne connaissais pas tout
simplement des choses ont changé depuis
44 ans de permis de conduire d'autres en
revanche insistent ils sont âgés certes
mais ne perdent pas pour autant leur
savoir-faire dans l'ensemble ça fait ça
fait quand même 40 que j'ai mon permis
je n'ai jamais eu de problème c'est vrai
que c'est important ils ont je pense que
dans l'ensemble les retraités restent
quand même dans le coup malgré quelques
lacunes dans l'ensemble je pense que on
arrive à suivre le code de la route
quand même à peu près quoi ce spectacle
était organisé dans le cadre de la
Semaine bleue elle se termine ce
dimanche
faut-il repasser son permis après un
certain âge la question est tabou en
raison sans doute de pas mal d'idées
reçues mais aussi par crainte de
discrimination qu'en pensez-vous en tout
cas c'est notre question du jour on vous
écoute je pense que ce serait tout à
fait normal quand même parce qu'on
arrive à un certain âge on a pu les
mêmes facultés on a pu les mêmes
réflexes que quand on est plus jeune oui
parce que certaines personnes avaient un
certain âge ou
une maîtrise pas
tout ce qui est visuel le l'audition
les facultés qu'on a encore la
possibilité les mouvements les gestes
enfin les réflexes tout ça c'est sûr
passer des tests vous voyez c'est sûr
sans interdire c'est vraiment la
personne a envie de conduire pas
forcément une limite d'âge mais en tout
cas un suivi plus important plus
régulier il faut surtout une
surveillance médicale quelle que soit
l'âge parce qu'il y a des des plus
jeunes qui sont sous médicaments qui
sont dangereux et mais des personnes
âgées qui sont très dangereuses
effectivement bah tiens certainement il
faut vraiment surveiller de façon
bien régulière à mon avis
en bref Alexandre Costanzo 20 ans devait
comparaître ce mercredi devant le
tribunal correctionnel de Versailles
pour son implication dans les émeutes de
Trappes en juillet dernier le jeune
homme est accusé de violence de
rébellion à l'encontre de trois
policiers dans la nuit du 19 au 20
juillet lui évoque une bavure de des
coups et des insultes également
seulement le procès n'a pas eu lieu il a
été reporté c'est la seconde fois elle a
fait réjouger trop complexe c'était une
audience intermédiaire pour faire le
point qui se tiendra maintenant le 5
février et puis j'ajoute que le procès
d'un autre et métier de trappe qui avait
aussi été reporté doit s'ouvrir le 30
octobre nous aurons bien sûr l'occasion
d'y revenir rester avec nous la semaine
prochaine pour le 7 8 l'actu loisirs
sport pour conclure ce journal avec un
tournoi d'échecs le Tourdan de la dame
noire le club de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
qui fête ses 25 ans en 2013 pour
l'occasion le traditionnelle rendez-vous
de l'automne a été couplé à un nouveau
rendez-vous entre maître c'est le titre
consacré voici le reportage d'Anthony re
ich
Julien ça adapte participe au tournoi
des Maîtres pour tenter de décrocher sa
première norme en langage courant gagner
6 matchs sur 9 notamment contre des
joueurs titrés au rang de Maître
International ce qui lui permettra
d'obtenir le rang de mettre à son tour
après trois normes réussies à l'issue de
synchrone le joueur charentais est
imposé une fois et à concéder 4 matchs
nuls dont une cinquième partie donnée
sur une erreur de Genèse le parti direct
il faut l'oublier parce que j'étais
complètement gagnant j'ai fait que match
nul donc voilà un peu déçu d'hier mais
il faut absolument faire abstraction de
ça et puis aujourd'hui c'est de gagner
quoi on peut jouer jusqu'à 5h 6h pour
une seule partie
et puis quelquefois on est très bien sur
les chéquiers et puis la fatigue un
manque de concentration fait qu'on fait
une petite erreur parce qu'on appelle
une imprécision et tout de suite en fait
la partie elle peut se retourner et puis
et puis on perd la partie quoi alors
qu'on était très bien sur l'échiquier
le joueur de La Rochelle a bien réagi en
remportant sa sixième ronde face à un
autre Français Julien lamorelle et comme
dans tout sport stratégique qui se
respecte les maîtres n'arrivent pas
comme des fleurs sur l'échiquier les
maîtres se préparent se préparent des
jours voir pour certains des semaines à
l'avance par rapport à leurs adversaires
c'est-à-dire qu'ils vont regarder sur
internet quels sont les résultats des
matchs précédents de leurs adversaires
pour pouvoir justement
se préparer au mieux et donc
effectivement après quand il y a
vraiment une différence de niveau on se
dit bon bah là je vais faire 0 points et
puis par contre on essaie de se bâtir un
tableau de marche pour avoir le nombre
de points nécessaires sur ce premier
tournoi international des maîtres 10
joueurs s'affrontent pendant 9 jours les
dernières parties se joueront ce
dimanche
fin de ce journal bon week-end je vous
retrouve lundi en direct des 18 heures